[音楽]
あのトイザらスのさーん福袋買ったんよ
でさん開けてとってあなたの動画見たら開けとったんよ
600本
分ねえよねでだ助けて
ほんとにこのままだとパクリって言われちゃう本当に
じゃあこれは抹茶ポスター上げてて俺は果実と上げてだからさ一人ではいはい
そうでサジットかけた夜明け上から本人にパクリじゃないですという要素を得たいの
ですよ私は
するそれたじゃあ俺の皆に言えばいいんだ何かよはいみなさん聞いてくださいござい
ますよね
って間違っえっじゃあホラーでも中身くれなレザーナカミー一生かどうか気になら
なきゃいいって言うけどみんな2ちゃんの福袋とか見た後に本当にトイザらスく僕は
中目黒
なんかどうかっていうのを確認団のたびにちょっと見てくださいさあ
はい
ぜひマホとも見てくださいにお願いしますよろしくお願いします
あかりですこれ築港ん
[音楽]
僕もねまずね柴田場で福袋買いに行く暇はなく実家に頼る暇はなくを育つぽよ正月は2
個30が編集していたらて前になってしまいそのまま徹夜の勢いで言ったスノーボード
もキャラでて精神通り水作しておりほぼ2時間くらいしか滑れず帰ってしまったという
再公募した事過ごします肇社長です
使うよ
欲しいの一瞬で買ってきましたこちらトイザらスの福袋でございますちなみにこの福袋
睦会に入ってません後輩に買ってきてもらえますっ聞いた話ってかおおっ
やっぱここ横に並んでこのきたよで稼げちゃうとなんかめっちゃ重いです外れさんお
いっすよこれをすぎてなんかもう持ち手が取れちゃったって言ってましたねどんだけ
重いんっ
んじゃ
なんだこれ
安いなまで何キロ体重あるんだろうかかってあげろ
4.6km 四捨五入すると約こちら
5キロの福袋ってなかなかないですよて病床活動がこれで最後にさせて下さいスクール
を開けますもう曲上げていきますや他の第二弾は4000円辞書4000円者の活用が
ないと僕的に困りますからちょっと出てきたもの1個ずつあの俺の所の偏見って寺を
つけています個人的な価値
ですなぜみんなが欲しいとか好きなものが出ても私のパッチ金やすい価格に設定しても
行いで開け
山へなんかすごい寿司でネットにくれえっ
ハッハイッ
あ
はいこレターウォーズ the
4鯖言い返すああああ
i ターンのプルタブスターウォーズのキャラクターを仮面ですね定格ジョナが長い絵
が見れなくていたことないけどスターウォーズ好きです会慰労れ回路連って人ですね
これは
[音楽]
ません行為まででもあれじゃない
これもこれが今 thk
[音楽]
ブーブーを買ったぞ
120円ではなかなか良い出だしを最初でちょっともっと買ってやっていきますをそう
だから服僕はレベルが違う
はい
秘宝よっカイエンヴェルムカ石&メダルセット zero 2
妖怪をつけのあれですね多分まあなんかすごい昔感が凄い
これ何か他の奴にくっつきで遊ぶ奴ですねはい
50円何かがないと遊べないっていうのはさあ初めて買う人からするとサーメじゃん
なるべくその場で遊べるのが欲しいなって思ってますね
ベッカー何コレ
はい我々も一歩前の仮面ライダーに気がするなぁ
デラックスガシャコンキースらっしゃーいなんか鍵が入ってますねだって
カメラいいんだってこれでもカメラ見てたら遅いんだろうなぁ
でも凄いけん時代がカッコイイですねとてもあれもこれも絶対なんか入れて遊べやつ
でしょ
別売りのライダーガジェットをダブルです
えっと
[音楽]
んっ
全事例てどう変わる形になりますっても3時間こんな短いと敵はどうぞ
[音楽]
うっああああ
[拍手]
ここをストーンものが崩れ移ろうと思いますから
パパーン
ispot パー170
うざいマニアックなものが出ると困っちゃいます
俺のスっているものが出るとスッゲーでしたらいいんだよってこいのまだこれいきます
はいもうこうのては枠でラック3ほいじゃあこの子の多分体の一部かな俺だけだとこの
子の足にしかならねー
4でもカフェカッコイーカッコいい関係
かっけえ惚れ走れるようなこっちああ
ああ言えば一致ようこいつだけでもここで変形することができました700円ねぇ
1個だ滑るのかなああああこれ今んとこ剤1個で遊べるのさ本当にもうさー
me
goo
none
いやーこれ健康困りますよこれこのままだと俺ほんとこれしかそれじゃないですけど
まともに国家大事な本当に
はい
ドキハラおバカな創生これ誰かどうかで見ても誰だこれ
プーッラビ
ちぇっ
またでパッチして取り消して通知としてタッチしてあっはい
二チャットもする方です800円はいもう
スターウォーズ済みがすごいぐライトセーバーじゃないかな
かっこいいやばい
なんてめっちゃかっこいいや
かっこええすごい
すごい
すごいしまう凄い待って心これはこれ当たったらを失いってこれ遂げるつ時計ですよ
なくまあ面白いけど
次々に生え
グラックス宮玉セット02タームでこの後にかけるやつですこれとまったく同じ形し
てるんですよ
2年撮影いきましょうはい
だーっ
わーべきしたスターウォーズにはこういう方もいるんですね
大変失礼いたしましたもう打つ音完全ねー完全にもうキャラ済んだけど雑魚この後でも
過ごした指にくっつきますねやばい
えっもうこんなら生地っぽいなぁ多分あったです
最後はこちらがハイデラックス8日煙幕ダムデラックス pot 冒険スタートキット
妖怪マグナ塗ってやってますね御旅めっちゃかっこいいけどこれ
を容器が溜まっています
car
me
[音楽]
思えやろ
駒荘へやのもう良い
あれともなくなっちゃったえっ
はん
病気が不要機が飛ばずだったと言っ
はい行くぜー
いやー
th
医療らー
家
じゃ
me
car
teame
me
wh 8版